Hello, and welcome to this video.
We are going to be doing the first exercise.
So we will be on slide 7 in the top right-hand corner,
and you should hopefully see this little scene here
where we have a number of different meshes
that are all in a sort of silver.
Now, what we're going to be doing here is
we're going to be looking at how you can use
Material Instance in order to control effects.
So this is sort of just a very, very short exercise.
And we're just going to be looking at these materials.
So you should hopefully have the material shown
in the Content Browser.
If we double-click and open that one up here,
you can see that we've got something
that looks a little bit like this.
Now, this has actually got an effect that's part of it.
What we're doing is we're using the bounding box,
and we are using that in order to control the effect.
Now you can see here we have the subtract value,
and then we are plugging something into the Emissive
and the Opacity Mask.
So if I was to take this fade amount,
change it to 0.5,
you can see that the mesh has gone halfway down it.
It's got this sort of glowing outer ring.
If I was to apply this and jump back into the level,
you'd see that all of the objects that we have
that are using this material also have now lost their top halves.
So it's this fade amount value here,
which is controlling it.
So 0.5 would mean 50% of the way through.
It would do 0.9.
It would mean that 90% of the way through.
But we want to be able to control this within the gauge.
And the first step for that is,
you can change that back to zero,
is to make sure that this is a parameter.
What a parameter means is it means
that we're going to be able to control this externally.
I'm going to call this parameter Fade Amount,
and I will apply and save.
Now you'll see next to this,
this we have a material instance for the same material.
And that's what is applied to these different meshes.
If I was to open this up now and drag this across
so that we can see,
we can now see we have the fade amount material
that we created is an option to be updated here.
And if I was to push tick,
you would now see as I drag this,
the effect runs through all of the different meshes.
So everything that is owning that material instance
is now controllable by this variable.
Now that's relatively straightforward,
but we're going to look later
how we can change that programmatically.
And again, because we've used the bounding box,
this means that this material will work on any mesh
that it is assigned to.
Great, so that is the complete of the exercise.
Next, we will look at doing this programmatically at runtime.